[Music]  any kind of black hole that could pass  through the solar system would be  pulling on all the planets harder than  the Sun does and so it's just going to  totally disrupt the gravitational  balance of the solar system the black  hole would literally tear planets from  their orbits and smash them into each  other  it's just an epic disaster it's a bull  in a china shop  if it got close enough to say Jupiter it  could actually pull the moons of Jupiter  away from the planet itself it would  just be flinging planets left and right  everywhere as it whipped through the  solar system leaving disaster in its  wake  if a black hole approached earth all  that gravity would rip asteroids from  their orbits and hurl them toward our  planet  the Earth's surface would become an  inferno it would be the beginning of the  end  first it would swallow up the atmosphere  then the planet itself  [Applause]  destroying an entire solar system is  nothing to a black hole